fin et c'est le quatrième axe nous
sommes rejoints sur une évidence
nous ne pouvons pas rester engagés
militairement aux côtés d' autorité de
fait dont nous ne partageons ni la
stratégie ni les objectifs cachés c'est
la situation à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui au mali la lutte
contre le terrorisme ne peut pas tout
justifier
elle ne doit pas sous prétexte d'être
une priorité absolue se transformer en
exercice de conservation indéfinie du
pouvoir elle ne peut pas non plus
justifier une escalade de la violence
par le recours à des mercenaires dans
les exactions sont documentés en
république centrafricaine et dont
l'exercice de la force n'est encadrés
par aucune règle ni par aucune
convention
dans ces conditions la france et ses
partenaires engagés dans des missions de
lutte contre le terrorisme à savoir les
états participant à la task force
takouba ont pris la décision de retirer
leur présence militaire au mali
ce retrait se traduira par la fermeture
des emprises de gossip de ménaka et de
gao il sera effectuée de manière
ordonnée avec les forces armées
maliennes et avec la mission des nations
unies au mali
durant cette période nous maintiendrons
nos missions de soutien au profit de la
minus mans
s'agissant de l'engagement de nos
partenaires européens il sera maintenu
et s'intégrera dans l'art et
articulations de ce dispositif
avec l'accord des autorités nigériennes
des éléments européens seront
repositionnées aux côtés des forces
armées nigériennes dans la région
frontalière du mali